nick cage oh my god i love you
nick cage
nick you've been living at the sunset
tower for over a year they love having
me there you owe them six hundred
thousand dollars okay i'm gonna deal
with all that but i'm gonna get this
next roll
and when i do
all of that changes then i'm back not
that you went anywhere
nicholas cage oh my god i love you
he was so good in the rock what about
gone in 60 seconds have you seen croods
too no i'm 44 years old why would i see
croods too i've seen face off and con
air we got another offer what's it about
you head to southern spain and you
attend a wealthy gentleman's birthday
party
i would never do that it's a million
bucks nick
i'll take it
the guy that owns this house what's his
name cubby yeah
mr k excuse me is harvey going to want
me to uh you know i'm not sure i
understand look it's hobbies
[Music]
in the cage
that's freaking cool i am so happy that
you're here
is this supposed to be me it's
protest
i'll give you 20 000
[Music]
what do you got there divine inspiration
i'm paranoid let's just get up on the
count of three and run
they're coming grab my hand
you're heavier than you look i have a
very big head
mr cage
it turns out we could have just walked
around wow yourself
[Music]
[Music]